il titolo del mio intervento
è magia e
management sono due parole molto
distanti tra di
loro che difficilmente capita di trovare
accostate Ebbene nei prossimi minuti
eseguirò per voi un gioco di prestigio
che consiste nel connettere nella vostra
mente queste due parole Management e
tutto quello che dovete fare è rimanere
seduti e seguire il filo del mio
discorso dall'inizio alla fine vi
prometto che tutti i pezzi verranno a
convergere parola di
Mago iniziamo subito parliamo un po' di
magia magia è una parola che nella
nostra cultura evoca dei significati
abbastanza ambivalenti per magia si
intende qualcosa di di di oscuro di
dubbio di probabilmente di falso di
ingann
magia è qualcosa che non si capisce bene
se è vera oppure no e se come funziona
allo stesso tempo
magia è associata con tutto ciò che è
misterioso affascinante straordinario e
quindi magia evoca le sensazioni D Le
emozioni della meraviglia e dello
stupore per questa circostanza vorrei
proporvi una delle mie definizioni
preferite di magia è quella dello
scrittore Arthur
Clark secondo il qu tecnologia
sufficientemente avanzata e pressoché
indistinguibile dalla vera magia in
questo caso il fulcro della definizione
sta sulla parola tecnologia che nella
sua accezione etimologica greca di Tecne
significa un insieme di conoscenze
pratiche per realizzare
qualcosa per cui ci vuole una Tecne per
costruire un palazzo per costruire una
lampada o per dipingere un quadro o per
scrivere una poesia per cui tecn è un
insieme di conoscenze che ci permettono
di fare
qualcosa Nel corso delle delle epoche è
stato chiamato mago colui il quale
dispone di un certo tipo di conoscenze
occulte e per occulte intendo nascoste
che non sono note alle persone comuni
Ebbene grazie a queste conoscenze
occulte il mago può realizzare e fare
accadere delle cose straordinarie e
quindi a seconda di quanto è sofisticata
la tecnologia del Mago i risultati del
suo operare saranno considerati appunto
straordinario o addirittura magici dalle
persone che che non sono iniziate ad un
certo tipo di conoscenza nel corso delle
delle epoche nel corso dell'evoluzione
del pensiero umano magia e tecnologia
sono stati due concetti molto vicini Si
sono Sono due binari un po' paralleli
che si sono inseguiti nel corso del
tempo I maghi di ogni luogo e di ogni
tempo Hanno dedicato le loro energie
alla trasmissione del pensiero a
distanza al volo quindi la possibilità
di spostarsi a grandi distanze In
brevissimo tempo oppure la capacità di
accedere a enormi informazioni con la
propria mente o ancora un concetto caro
agli alchimisti I maghi maghi Appunto
alchimisti Si sono cimentati con la
ricerca delle lisiri di lunga vita in
modo da prolungare la vita
indefinitamente Ebbene nel corso del
tempo quelle che un tempo sono state le
promesse della Magia sono state
realizzate ed implementate sotto forma
tecnologica per cui in qualche modo con
il passare del tempo sono diventate
disponibili per un gran numero di
persone qu quelle che erano le promesse
della magia per cui ad oggi non sappiamo
se i maghi avessero trovato il loro
elisir di lunga vita oppure no Sta di
fatto che ad oggi con le tecnologie
farmaceutiche con l'ingegneria genetica
Stiamo andando esattamente in quella
direzione e piuttosto che le tecnologie
delle
telecomunicazioni piuttosto che le
tecnologie informatiche tutti mezzi
tutte tecniche appunto tutte tecnologie
che permettono di realizzare di
implementare quelle che appunto sono
state intuizioni e ambiti di studio da
parte dei Maghi di ogni luogo e di ogni
tempo per cui lo spirito della Magia nel
suo nucleo più profondo è quello di
studiare e conoscere Eh i i segreti
della natura In modo da implementarli da
utilizzarli a beneficio del maggior
numero di persone per cui lo spirito
della magia non è svanito ha solo
cambiato forma e ha preso forma appunto
sotto forma tecnologica
ehm e bene A questo punto vorrei
rivelarvi alcuni segreti tre segreti
della magia che sono delle conoscenze eh
molto pratiche sono un po' il distillato
di alcuni secoli di tradizioni ermetiche
Ebbene Chissà mettere in pratica in modo
consapevole e opportuno questi segreti
può realizzare delle vere e proprie
magie i segreti sono i seguenti Il primo
è che la realtà non è sempre ciò che
appare nel corso dei secoli gli uomini
si sono interrogati sul concetto di
realtà Cioè In realtà è solo quello che
possiamo che riusciamo a vedere con gli
occhi e toccare con le mani o ci sono
dei risvolti volti c'è dell'altro anche
se non lo riusciamo a percepire
direttamente per cui nel corso dei
secoli sono state messe appunto varie
narrative varie storie per esplorare
appunto Il concetto di realtà e
dell'esistenza di molteplici livelli di
realtà per cui che si tratti di del mito
della caverna di Platone piuttosto che
il concetto del velo di Maia delle
filosofie
orientali Ovvero le trasposizioni
cinematografiche di Matrix o Truman Show
sono narrative diverse per puntare il
dito nella stessa direzione e cioè che
le nostre percezioni sono limitate e
qualsiasi nostra rappresentazione della
realtà è una pallida appunto
rappresentazione di quello che c'è là
fuori
ehm in un certo senso il compito
dell'arte quindi il ruolo dell'artista è
quello di offrire il suo di interpretare
la sua realtà attraverso i suoi occhi in
modo da offrire a beneficio degli altri
del prossimo del pubblico uno spaccato
di realtà Eh che gli altri non potre
avere attraverso il loro limitato punto
di vista per cui per dirla con le parole
di
Paul L'arte non riproduce ciò che è
visibile ma rende visibile ciò che
spesso non lo è per cui il punto di
partenza di ogni creazione magica è
proprio questa presa di coscienza che
esistono molteplici livelli di
realtà il secondo segreto è che
l'immaginazione crea la realtà anche
questo credo che qualsiasi artista di
qualsiasi scuola di qualsiasi tempo
sia abbastanza d'accordo con questa
verbalizzazione Ebbene I maghi di ogni
luogo e di ogni tempo hanno considerato
nell'immaginazione lo strumento
principale addirittura la funzione più
alta dello spirito umano per poter
navigare attraverso questi diversi
livelli di realtà nelle splendide parole
del musicista Peter Gabriel tutti i
palazzi e tutte le macchine sono stati
in un certo momento soltanto un sogno
nella testa di qualcuno detto In altre
parole tutto quello che C circonda prima
di prendere forma nella realtà materiale
oggettiva nasce Come idea come
intuizione Come pensiero O come visione
nella mente di qualcuno per cui credere
nella magia che è un'espressione un po'
bizzarra credere nella magia significa
credere nel potere supremo
dell'immaginazione di dare forma alla
realtà in
modi realmente
magici per cui in qualche in un certo
senso è cosa che è anche è stata
validata dalle neuroscienze noi in buona
misura siamo diventiamo ciò che siamo e
quindi l'insieme di Memi che
costituiscono la magia sono in un certo
senso una specie di software per fare
accadere per riuscire a concepire cose
che per l'appunto sono
magiche infine l'ultimo segreto è che la
realtà è fatta di parole e cioè la magia
e l'arte della parola che incanta e ha
effetti concreti sulla realtà per cui le
parole che noi diciamo danno forma alla
nostra realtà in modi più profondi e più
spinti e più concreti di quanto gener
generalmente non
riconosciamo per cui addirittura
qualcuno si spinge fino a dire che se ci
fosse un singolo segreto della Magia
sarebbe proprio questo come dice questo
pensatore postmoderno il vero segreto
della Magia è che il mondo è fatto di
parole e cioè tutti quelli che conoscono
le parole giuste possono realizzare
pressoché qualsiasi cosa e questa è una
lezione che funziona da chi si occupa di
politica o Chi si occupa di pubblicità
fino al venditore Porta a porta e tutto
quello che ci sta in mezzo per cui ad
oggi oltre ai linguaggi tradizionalmente
noti Abbiamo assistito all'emergere di
linguaggi di nuovi linguaggi per dare
forma alla realtà linguaggi che sono
assolutamente concreti nei loro effetti
sulla realtà sto pensando ai linguaggi
dell'informatica le cui istruzioni
appunto possono avere degli effetti
molto concreti e i linguaggi
dell'informatica sono la nuova versione
di linguaggi esoterici ed iniziatici che
sono assolutamente oscuri a chi non è
addentro questo tipo di tecnologia per
cui qui che si tratti per esempio
conoscendo le parole giuste questa donna
ha venduto 500 milioni di libri e sempre
conoscendo le parole giuste questo
giovanotto ha 500 milioni di amici
Ditemi voi se queste due persone non
credono nel potere magico delle parole
Ebbene che si tratti di parole o di
codici dell'informatica in ultima
analisi La realtà è fatta di simboli e
cioè noi navighiamo in una foresta di
simboli che sono delle entità atte ma il
cui effetto sulla realtà è assolutamente
concreto come ben sa chi si occupa di
branding o di appunto di pubblicità nel
senso più lato del termine per cui per
sintetizzare questi tre segreti della
Magia il mago è colui il quale riconosce
che la realtà è un costrutto dinamico
fluido in continuo divenire che è
possibile influenzare Quindi è possibile
guidarne il corso utilizzando in modo
opportuno l'immaginazione
e manipolando opportunamente i giusti
simboli Ebbene tutto questo vale
assolutamente al 100% per il manager
contemporaneo Ed ecco che parliamo di
Management anche il management è una
tecnologia è una tecnologia per fare
succedere delle cose nella realtà
utilizzando il lavoro di altri appunto a
supporto per cui ed è chiunque si occupi
di Management sa che ad un certo livello
di complessità e sofisticazione il
management piuttosto che una scienza
esatta è più vicina ad un'arte magica
per cui qualsiasi manager consapevole
del proprio ruolo può testimoniare
questa cosa Ebbene le negli ultimi
decenni il management è un pezzo
rilevante della nostra della nostra
società visto l'importanza del modello
aziendale nel sistema capitalistico
ehm noi nel nell'ambito delle aziende
assistiamo all'emergere di proprietà
emergenti Appunto che sono completamente
non lineari e delle catene di
causa-effetto che sono assolutamente
opache e misteriose e quindi qualcuno
chiama questa cosa cigni neri Ebbene le
le osservazioni che seguono sono tratte
dalla mia esperienza in ambito aziendale
in in veste di ingegnere meccanico e di
consulente per lo sviluppo delle
competenze manageriali le seguenti idee
puntano il dito nella direzione di una
una serie di competenze del diciamo
dell'archetipo del manager con
temporaneo e partiamo da qui ogni 2
anni la IBM conduce una ricerca
internazionale nella quale intervista
alcune migliaia di capi dienda di tutto
il
mondo per cercare di capire quali sono
delle tendenze del mondo delle aziende
per l'appunto ebene l'ultimo di questo
sondaggio che risale
al0 mostra dei risultati molto
interessanti dal nostro punto di vista e
i risultati sono i seguenti la
stragrande maggioranza dei manager
intervistati e dei capi d'azienda
ritiene che le caratteristiche del
manager di oggi e sempre più quelle del
futuro sia la capacità di saper leggere
dei segnali e saper
captare riconoscere delle tendenze
emergenti e quindi fare del suo meglio
per facilitare l'ingresso nella realtà
delle idee opportune e inoltre oltre il
70% di questi manager intervistati
ritiene che le due competenze
fondamentali del manager moderno e
contemporaneo sono proprio
l'immaginazione e l'intuito che sono
appunto due caratteristiche magiche per
eccellenza per come ci stiamo
raccontando questa
cosa l'immaginazione per vedere quello
che è invisibile agli occhi e l'intuito
per per prendere delle decisioni anche
strategiche da appunto da abbinare alla
razionalità la seconda capacità che deve
avere appunto il manager contemporaneo è
il management del significato e cioè il
manager deve essere in grado
riconoscendo che la realtà è una
costruzione appunto dinamica deve essere
in grado di tessere di costruire delle
narrative e di tessere delle trame che
siano significative per motivare se
stesso e i propri collaboratori In altre
parole Management del significato
significa riuscire a captare segnali che
emergono dal caos ed interpretarli e
tradurli in un linguaggio che sia
comprensibile agli altri per cui ancora
una volta sia il lavoro dell'artista che
lavoro del Mago è un lavoro di
traduzione dal caos al segnale per
esempio una nota narrativa un noto
cambio di narrativa che è avvenuto negli
ultimi anni nel mondo del del business
Management in particolare relativa alla
figura stessa del manager si è passati
dall'immagine del manager come un
Combattente guerriero che appunto sul
campo di battaglia in modo sanguinoso e
belligerante conduce il suo lavoro si è
passati ad una narrativa un po' più
feconda e più organica e pacifista del
manager visto come un direttore
d'orchestra il quale è in grado di far
emergere l'armonia piuttosto che imporla
con la forza e ovviamente non mancano
narrative di di manager considerati dei
veri e propri maghi in virtù sia delle
dell'ampiezza delle loro visioni che
della che dell'impatto pratico delle
loro intuizioni infine
ehm l'ultima caratteristica del manager
del nuovo millennio è la coltivazione
del sé e cioè il manager deve essere una
persona coltivata nel senso di una
persona colta la quale deve affiancare a
competenze tecniche magari a un NBA una
ricchezza e una
multidisciplinarità di esperienze altre
a bilanciamento appunto delle delle
competenze tecniche per cui coltivare se
stessi significa un processo di
apprendimento
continuo riuscire a ad essere sempre più
consapevoli del proprio potere creativo
da mettere a disposizione del sistema
azienda nel quale si è immersi per cui
Ecco perché dal mio punto di vista il
manager contemporaneo può beneficiare
può essere ispirato dal pensiero magico
come una mappa non lineare
per una mappa non lineare per riuscire a
navigare in quella terra di mezzo
dove dove l'immaginazione è più
importante della della conoscenza isita
e dove nulla è vero ma tutto è possibile
per cui per
concludere come promesso all'inizio
vorrei rimettere insieme tutti i pezzi
sia a beneficio di quelli che hanno
seguito il filo del discorso fino ad ora
sia per quelli che invece si sono persi
nella selva dei simboli ed ecco perché
c'erano anche alcune immagini per il
vostro intrattenimento Ebbene per
rimettere i pezzi insieme intendo questo
sintetizzò quello che ho appena
raccontato E come si fa a mettere
insieme insieme connettere magia e
management Ebbene per fare questo basta
un semplice filo di
cotone Ebbene tutta la nostra vita
dall'inizio fino alla fine è fatta di
tanti pezzi ci sono i nostri
ricordi i
luoghi le persone i nostri
desideri le tecnologie e conferenze del
Ted
tutta la nostra vita è un insieme di
eventi del mondo esterno e immagini
mentali che abbracciano Passato presente
e futuro e tutti questi pezzi formano un
intricato groviglio in cui si perde di
vista ciò che è reale e ciò che invece è
solo nella nostra mente ebbene la
capacità del mago e la magia consiste
nella capacità di riuscire a vedere al
di là delle
apparenze l'unità di fondo di questi
pezzi che sono dei frammenti del gioco
cosmico dove tutto è connesso e in
continua
trasformazione